there was an interesting opinion piece
in the New York Post suggesting that
bullies because of the way we're
treating them we're gonna basically
we're gonna grow a generation of super
bullies they said that one of the
reasons is because of Facebook post and
Twitter and snapchat and kick and
everything else that we first saw up
we've separated the bully you used to
have to bully in person now you can
bully separate so that's sort of
empowering to the bullies and the second
point that parents are not as
responsible as they once were and kids
are doing all kinds of things and the
parents are just completely disconnected
because you know they don't see a kid
come home with the punched face or a
bruised knuckle and I thought it was
kind of interesting because everyone's
talking about bullying constantly first
off I kind of think that we need a
certain level of bullying I'm a little
worried about the never ending bullies
or bad thing because when you get to the
real world there are bullies and if
you've never experienced it as a child
doesn't that set you up for a really
rough life that's a really interesting
take about it I mean I think that it's I
just came off as Pro bully but no I mean
I think it's part of look everybody's
had bullies for ever growing up from the
beginning of time but I do think and you
know with with this sort of
cyberbullying that happens it's it's
real and it's legitimate and you can say
anything to somebody on Twitter you can
say anything to somebody on Facebook I
mean when you read the kind of hate
that's on you know comments on stories
and articles it's it's you know people
that can hide behind that stuff you read
the things that they're saying about us
right now below us really do you think
it's any worse actually all the all the
Facebook stuff and Twitter's up as well
is any worse than when we were in junior
high school and it happened to our faces
yeah because I think it's a lot easier
for cowards to hide behind the veil of
anonymity these days and just say
whatever they want and go completely
unchecked I think that like when you're
face to face there's still the
accountability of like okay well what if
the bully the kid that I'm bullying has
had to you know has had enough and wants
to punch me in the face like that
doesn't exist on the internet right
didn't it happen where people would
you'd write on the blackboard you know
so and let Mac sucks and you put that on
blackboard then everybody would come in
and see that right a lot of trouble I
feel like if you
that so yeah maybe there's the same sort
of you gonna put the same sort of rules
do you think part of problem is we've
taken violence so we've shamed violence
to the point that in the old days the
old days in the 1980s let's say like
there were a lot of parents I'm sure
that would if their son was getting
bullied they would have said well you
got to just punch him in the face and
then he'll stop bullying you and
actually that really works most of the
time I think and now we're so afraid of
violence at all cost that we wouldn't
you would never say that if you were to
say that to your kid now you would be
shunned right if that came out that you
said your kid punch the bully did that
ever work did the punch the bully thing
everywhere I don't think it does because
I think that like you your parents are
like oh man you should stand up and
punch him and then he's a big he's
bigger than you and it never happens
like it does in the movies where you
want punch right he goes down the girl
runs up I don't know it never happened
for me is that just a movie so um so
basically Biff in back my future that's
my main thing you know work for you I or
were you the bully bully but I always
tried to talk my way out of
confrontations and I think that's
helpful you know I think it's important
to like to equip children with creative
faculties so that they're able to like
problem solving unique ways you know
whereas which so that maybe like a punch
isn't the only way out of a situation
you know yeah um but I mean that is kind
of like Carrie is so gratifying right
like she's like the bully girl who
finally like gets back at everybody in a
horrific way right boys yeah that seems
extreme so so you're endorsing lighting
the other children on fire yes pretty
much blog no yeah but that's I mean
carries a pretty endearing story because
she's the girl who's like been bullied
or whole life you know in comes from
really you know horrible background and
I mean it's a horror movie but I think
there's other ways though probably like
you're talking about with words maybe um
and you know work with the counselor
recommend not as exciting a movie though
well especially for Halloween time final
thought on this how much should the
parents actually be responsible because
this is the new thing now we're hearing
that a lot of times the parents do know
what's going on and now people are
trying to take legal action against the
parents because they didn't stop the kid
from bullying
I feel like that's a dangerous slope too
because parents can't be watching kids
all the time and unless they're
literally like coaching them on the
bullying I don't know how responsible a
parent could be for everything that a
child does right I mean I you know I
don't know I feel like you got to really
be paying attention of course I don't
have any kids so it's easy for me to say
I know Facebook and Twitter when I don't
have to deal with it your parents know
everything you're doing right now yeah
they do they'd be out there writing the
comments absolutely
anonymously yeah we'll find out what do
you think do you think parents can be
held responsible for some of this stuff
I'm you know I I think that it's a
parent's job to just raise the kid with
values you know of kindness and and and
you know empathy and to just teach them
to sort of spread that message you know
and and and to again talk their way out
of things to give them like a creative
tool kit with which to solve problems
that helps that goes a long way all
right people when you're commenting on
this please use your creative tool kit
what was another buzzword you said their
empathy use a little empathy would yeah
hey guys don't forget the Reuben reports
brought to you by Cooper calm they've
got up to 75% off pet treats toys and
more and if you use code RR you get
another 20% off that's a lot off there
is a link in the description right down
below code RR 20% off make your pet
happy